em 2009 o ministro em 12 anos e toca
contrabaixo e vem me anel
este é o meu trabalho já em quatro
cordas monstro normal feito uma velha
tem essas cordas mas também pode ser que
outras maneiras
a mãe permanece calma nós é melhor isso
que eu vim cá falar eu venho falar das
objetivas ainda disse custa caro
ou seja você tem muitos objetivos na
vida mas agora vocês vão gostar mais do
que deus do que os outros e tem
trabalhar muito mais nessa mas nos podem
focar sones é o nosso objetivo principal
mas já outros dizem que isso não está
fácil e promete é porque não está por
isso tenha sempre as opções tanto vamos
lá nosso dia-a-dia encontrar nós sempre
desafios e como é óbvio
temos de arranjar soluções para isso
temos que ter várias opções e saber
fazer várias coisas é que nós gostamos
mais é o nosso céu azul claro com os no
céu azul não é só uma coisa a solar cuir
esquecer o resto das coisas com que nós
pensemos de nosso tempo também pode ter
uma tia da meo né
lá está vou falar domingo como sendo que
esta direcção aos oito anos e agora
vocês perguntam quem quer que esta
geração porque essa gerencial orquestra
prominas não tem dinheiro ou mesmo a
estudar música
hoje tem 12 anos como profissional e
olha que a sugestão já não vou brasil a
paris
uol curto muitas idéias e claro que eu
tenho trabalhar para chegar lá não me
sentei lá olha vamos sentar aqui e as
coisas acontecem só assim não eu estudo
contra o avaí está a estudar piano e é
claro que também tem outras aulas
português matemática física química tudo
pois gosto mas temos todos os nossos
sacrifícios mas nem sempre tudo correr
bem
por exemplo uma vez eu tive um problema
no teste e não pude estudar um teste
instrumento então acho que o texto
enganei ou então em vez de chorar como
se outra vez e eu talvez até com esse
super mal outra vez eu estava em cima do
palco estava a procurar as coisas para o
conserto e lembrei esquece qualquer
coisa lá em baixo
então eu queria buscar mas como estava
muito de instrumento em cima do palco
caiu do palco há mais quem ensina não
violoncelo e fiquei com as quatro cordas
marcadas nas costas mas isso não importa
com o meu sonho é ser música trabalhar
numa grande orquestra com muitos músicos
tudo isso nem e clara é o sacrifício é
quem quis fazer
além de estudar muito e eu tenho que
sacrificar muito a parte do meu tempo
por exemplo eu gosto muito de passear
com as amigas da piscina mas desde que
entrei para essa escola já não tem tempo
pra isso porque para ser músico
profissional é preciso trabalhar muito
mais o que trabalhava antes mas vocês já
pensaram nisso já tem um objetivo nosso
e alunos em alguns não mas vai não
esqueçam que mesmo tendo de trabalhar a
regência tempo com os nossos jovens
estão lá todos mas nós velho tem 14 anos
sofreu o texto há quatro anos na
orquestra geração que estuda vejamos nos
copos inov-art mirandela pronta a
energia já falou da música um pouco mais
trabalho como esse que eu vou falar de
um lado mais sentimental
vamos falar música essencialmente nós
também vou contar um pouco da minha
história
é porque fez o que um dia você se
identificaram com ela agora também vou
apresentar o meu melhor amigo
o favorito e vou tocar num carro pra
vocês ficarem a conhecer o seu som
o
o roubo
o op
o bom ou o
o vôo ou o
o forró
o
tô
bom
ó
o bom
o
a lista por mim é uma espécie de refúgio
cumpre-me tinha ar comprimido desligar
da habilidade entrar num mundo só meu um
pouquinho ela a música não fez parte
desde o início desde os meus sejamos
mais ou menos que provam os problemas
familiares sempre fui um garoto
problemático
eu dava voz à violência e agressões de
conflitos que podia provocações dos
outros miúdos ainda conseguiam
compreender a minha situação
situação essa que não melhorou com a
entrada estaria numa instituição para
nós nós não vejamos
houve uma reviravolta na minha vida
passando a viver com familiares e foi a
partir desse momento comecei a viver com
este mundo maravilhosa música tendo
familiares directos ligado à música foi
o primeiro passo mas a entrada na
orquestra geração foi o grande empurrão
com sangue ser muito profissional tem
agora esse sonho foi fechando com
entrada e esteve naquela que eu
considero uma família foi me liga música
e sim porque é isso que eu sinto que nós
somos unidos que nós trabalhamos com o
objetivo de melhorar a cada dia é
centrada na música permitiu mudanças
significativas em mim o passado continua
nova foi substituído
na resposta o livro foram preenchidos
o tempo corre cá as coisas menos boas
antigamente
investimentos - vamos foi ocupado com o
sheik em 35 pela música dando um novo
brilho e sentido à minha vida
festa abertura de novas portas que me
ajudou a fechar aquelas que não teriam
qualquer sentido ou se estiver seguido
ao simplesmente os nossos caminhos que é
tão fácil disse que nós porque quando
podemos escolher o bom e fazer o que
está certo o valor que eu vou a música
dá motivação para continuar sempre mais
melhor harmonia
transmite faz de mim um ser humano mais
calmo com capacidade para sonhar com o
futuro
por isso eu consigo dizer vos com todos
os sentimentos mundo imagina lá em busca
de um herói depois de infinitos que use
o prêmio meu grandioso e com esta
pequena foi só eu tento dizer vos que
procurem o vosso vossa azul sigam sempre
bom sonho e se ao encontrar um cigano
até o fim lutem para que os concretize
briga
hum
a amm
ae ah ah ah ah
não não